thank you so much thank you thank you so
please hold your applause you know how
competitive Steve is
tonight is one of those magical moments
when the one-percenters come together to
honor some of our own and it has an
absolute thrill for me to have been
asked to honor my dear dear friend steve
beshear al-assad Martin actually it's
more than a thrill it's a complete and
utter obligation Steve there are so many
people more worthy than me to speak
about you but as they told the Academy
Saturday is such a good TV night the
governor's awards are considered the
highest honor an actor can receive in
mid-november
I remember when I got my governor's
award it feels like it was only five
years from now some good news Steve
President Obama said that if you like
your Oscar you can keep it
Wow Steve an Oscar an Oscar and we all
said there was simply no way Steve could
top the birth of his child but the Oscar
of course is different from a child
Steve is willing to hold his Oscar the
word genius has been used a lot tonight
so I might as well call Steve one
but I think it's safe to say that Steve
Martin is a genius not particularly true
but safe
and I believe that genius rubs off on
all of us
for example Steve's passion is
philosophy and right now I don't think
there's one person in this room who
isn't wondering why am I here
truth be told I love Steve whenever I've
needed one he's always been there with a
line or a joke like that thing I just
said about loving Steve he wrote that
for me you know it's funny on the cab
ride here tonight because they wouldn't
send a car Adana me that of all the
people I have a fake show business
friendship with Steve is a star I'm fake
closest to wait a sec wait a sec did I
just call Steve a friend oh no no you
are so much more than just a friend you
sir are a business associate I mean he
was there when all three of my children
were conceived
I know that because I was out of town
making a movie at the time
when I think of Steve and it's not often
I think of someone who has earned a
reputation as a nice sky well not so
much earned as demanded for example when
you talk to Steve over lunch on the
phone he will simply not say anything
hateful about anyone unless he really
trusts you Steve also happens to be one
of the most thoughtful people I know no
matter where we eat he always knows the
name of the waitress which i think is
truly astounding that a he knows their
names and be that they're all named
Dollface and anyone who's ever visited
Steve's home and gone from room to room
are all struck by the very same
identical thought how many portraits can
one man possibly sit for
I think I I think the thing I love most
about Steve is he's not he's not afraid
to punch someone else's kid I think
that's his strength but as we are
gathered here to celebrate him tonight
the one thing that strikes all of us
more than anything else is this steve is
pale he looks like a page in a coloring
book that hasn't been colored yet he
actually once got a sunburn from his
Kindle reader in fact Steve is so white
he could be the next GOP nominee for
president but more importantly Steve is
a great actor whenever I see Steven the
screen I always think the same thing boy
is Steve acting
what's great about Steve is that he
never lets the script get in the way of
the performance he's decided upon in an
advance
I've been lucky enough to make four
comedies with Steve let's list them
shall we and please hold your applause
till the end three amigos okay go ahead
yes Father the bride
father the bride Part B Prince of Egypt
and of course Django Unchained
but Steve not just an actor he's a he's
also a brilliant writer and he got his
first job as a writer for The Smothers
Brothers show back in the 1960s because
he was dating one of the dancers on the
show oh by the way Steve Tommy tune
sends his regards says he's sorry you
can't make it tonight
Steve has even hosted the Oscars three
times all during the Academy Academy was
going after that coveted 65 to 80 year
old demographic but truly Steve I'm not
just speaking from the heart I'm also
speaking from the teleprompter when I
say
that you are a breathtakingly brilliant
staggering original who who has and
continues to inspire all of us Steve
Martin wannabes congratulations amigo
thank you thank you thank you for the
million last that we have shared and
thank you for so many years of not only
incomparable friendship but for your
guidance and your wisdom and that deeply
appreciated kindnesses that you've shown
not only to me but my entire family the
shorts simply adore you but you know
that and I don't know much but I do know
this that Steve's body of work will be
honored that we're honoring tonight will
be studied long after we're gone because
two things are timeless the artistry of
Steve Martin and community college